[Music]
india was one of the hardest hit
countries by the pandemic in the spring
of 2021 overwhelmed hospitals had to
turn covet 19 patients away often
leaving them to suffocate from lack of
oxygen
several months later the vaccination
drive is in full swing on tuesday only
around 14 300 new covet cases were
reported it's the lowest single day rise
in nearly eight months
but is the trend at risk now that the
festival season is underway
kovit is definitely still here people
are under the false impression that
kobit is over but it's still going on
health experts fear that india's popular
festivals could turn into super spreader
events and that history could repeat
itself
welcome to our kobe 19 special i'm
monica jones good to have you with us
durga puja the biggest celebration of
the year for those of bengali heritage
is underway amid ongoing kobit 19
restrictions attendees are required to
trade carefully maintaining a distance
from each other and from the
extraordinary works of art and
decoration because nobody wants the
festival to kick start another third
wave
it has been hectic almost non-stop
inside the structures that dot this part
of kolkata in india's west bengal state
but the work is winding down as artists
put the finishing touches on idols of
the goddess durga
and other deities
this will again be the event of the year
here the durka puja
normally it's a wildly busy week of art
culture food and crowds
despite this huge banner there will be
strict limitations for the second year
running on access to the fabled pondels
the temporary structures where the
goddess is housed
authorities are worried if they went
unrestricted it could be a coronavirus
super spreader event
this festival director says this is one
of the top art events in the world but
authorities insist most festivalgoers
will not be allowed within 25 feet of
the artworks
on the street masks are the rule
volunteers are handing them out and
you'd better put one on
if you're on camera
and especially if you're stopped by
police
[Applause]
the vaccination rate in these parts is
estimated at over 60 percent for those
receiving two doses
and vaccination drives are aiming to
bring up numbers ahead of the durga puja
artists and festival workers are forging
ahead as though it's any other year
well sadly it's not like any other year
which is why getting that life-saving
shot can make all the difference
but for many indians that's easier said
than done
it takes a lot of patience and west
bengal vaccines are still rare for
people and cities like silly guri it
means skewing all night
see we've brought food along
we came here in the evening and they
will hopefully vaccinate us in the
morning what can we do
it's really distressing we leave our
kids at home and come here we have to go
through so much to get vaccinated
prime minister modi wants 950 million
people to get their first dose by the
end of the year
india is on course to achieve this goal
but for those living in rural areas
getting that life-saving shot often
remains a dream
dr rajiv das gupta joins us now from
delhi where he's the chairperson of the
center of social media and community
health at jawaharlal nehru university so
very good to have you with us uh and
starting straight away with the topic of
vaccination we heard that the
vaccination rate in bengal is about 60
that is not bad how does this compare
though to other parts of india
thank you and first dogar puja greetings
from bengali though not in bengal at the
moment
yes west bengal's immunization coverage
has certainly been
better than many of the states and more
importantly and interestingly
the gender
the gender advantage has been in favor
of women rather than men which is
true for most of the country on an
average
however as you very rightly said
that
mass events mass congregations whether
of religious or political or any nature
are certainly a risk at this point
but it's also to be taken into account
along with india's high zero prevalence
rate which is uh
near about 80 percent uh going by the
last round
and that could be a blessing in disguise
and of course as far as i understand now
there's also a vaccine approved for kids
now how big a difference will this make
for all those festivals coming up
well it's only in the emergency
authorization stage
it's quite a distance from what was
announced today the second vaccine to be
approved uh to an actual rollout to a
vaccination program for kids that's
quite a bit of a journey but certainly
um it was a good news today and there's
a lot of optimism particularly as far as
children and adolescents go okay so
there's light at the end of the tunnel
there too but how worried are you that
this festival of durga puja could
eventually be a corona super spreader
event
well actually we don't know it's going
to be an interaction of two things one
a pretty high zero prevalence
which
is on account of a combination of two
things a reasonably good vaccination
coverage till this point particularly in
urban areas
plus uh immunity
post uh the delta tsunami that we had
which of course
came with its share of very
high levels of mortality in some parts
but they put two but the two put
together actually means that a
substantial proportion of the population
is protected but what's worrying is that
india currently has the largest
numbers of um
those individuals immunized with a
single vaccine that's partially
immunized population that in itself
is potentially worrisome plus the crowds
of course
worrisome because it could
promote mutants or worries and why
because
the protection is
not
that accorded by two doses of the
vaccine a very large proportion is still
partially immunized
not so much because a mutant would arise
in a very short time but yes if
transmission goes on the probability of
a mutant emerging does remain
theoretically possible
now you've already mentioned the
devastation of the second wave how well
prepared is the health sector now
well we all think that the health sector
is much better prepared now
i'm sure
that across states both state
governments and federal governments as
well as the private sector have taken a
range of measures a lot of learning has
happened and i i hope we should be able
to cope better but personally i do not
really expect another wave of that
magnitude unless something dramatically
different happens like those big
festivals which are uh extremely
traditional obviously and very important
uh in india uh do you think it's
feasible to say let's just cancel those
festival uh until the pandemic is over
or is that completely impossible
now the trend so far has been
uh
both on account both in parts of
governments as well as the courts who
have often stepped in
to issue a range of advisories now
some of those advisories are often
followed very strictly particularly last
year it was
this year for example in west bengal it
comes with a set of caveats do's and
don'ts
some of which may not
actually be uh be very conducive to
being in being implemented in letter and
spirit
okay uh dr rajiv das gupta thank you so
much and durga puja greetings to you as
well
thank you very much
time now for one of your questions and
over to our correspondent derek williams
what is the move variant
ii is mutating all the time and although
the vast majority of those genetic
changes
give rise to variants that disappear
quickly because they're just less
competitive than the variants that
currently dominate the coveted landscape
a few
change in ways that might make them more
competitive or more dangerous
new variants are identified by
sequencing their genomes and comparing
those genomes to earlier versions of the
virus genome
when a new variant appears to be
spreading rapidly in a particular
country or or more widely
healthcare authorities like at the who
start to track it and it can become
what's called
a variant of interest
the b
1621 variant also designated mu
was first detected in colombia
back in january it became quite
prevalent there
and it's since been involved in
outbreaks in other parts of south
america and and europe and the us
moo was designated as a variant of
interest at the end of august um the who
added it to that category because of
concerns that it might be able to better
get around
covet 19 vaccines
and current treatments there were some
indications
that it could be better at that than the
highly transmissible delta variant which
is affecting so many countries at the
moment
however for now at least
worries about mu really taking off are
dropping
numbers of confirmed cases caused by the
variant have fallen in many places
which a lot of experts think is because
it's being simply outperformed by delta
so
while it's still being watched carefully
fears about mu have eased at least for
the moment
[Music]
before we let you go people in sydney
are enjoying the first days of return
freedoms as the city ends its 106 day
pandemic restrictions
we are back and we are open sydney's
cafes and restaurants welcome back fully
vaccinated customers on monday after
nearly four months of lockdown as
australia's vaccination rollout gains
momentum authorities say it's time to
live alongside the virus and
reopen that's all for now thanks for
watching